uh we identifi the pain okay and this
pain got actually Amplified over the
years in different forms and this pain
was around allowing people to create
software that they
trust and initially it was just this
revolution of um creating software from
reusable components mostly open source
obviously and um and you know when you
start to assemble your software from
many many pieces and you don't have
control over these pieces um it becomes
a risk H and the initial risk was just
uh maybe this open source software that
you're using maybe it's going to um Get
Off the Grid like vanish from the
internet that what this event
specifically was how uh the trigger for
JE fog came to me for for for the main p
Factory welcome to 20-minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey each one
is different unique inspiring let's get
started 20-minute leaders is a proud
supporter of makeawish Israel and Tech
to peace and is in proud collaboration
with secret cord Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside FM Fusion VC Birthright Excel
J impact leap Google for startups and
hippo and in media partnership with
[Music]
ctech yav lman welcome to 20 minut leers
I'm so excited and honored to have you
here I've actually been very excited for
this episode for quite some time so I'm
particularly looking forward to these 20
minutes thank you so much for joining me
today my pleasure
M so um you have um introduction has a
limited n need here H you are the
founder and CTO of uh one of the most
incredible and um one of the most
incredible companies and stories uh
obviously of of Israel but but really
globally you're you're the founder in C
of jrog um a software company really
looking at taking the leap of digital
Transformations with thousands of
customers and um a company that I think
probably every entrepreneur and every
engineer um knows about and so I'm I'm
really looking forward to hearing your
own personal Journey as a technologist
your your vision 15 years ago in
founding jrog and how you're seeing the
world of digital Transformations and
where where we're headed and and where
you thought we were going to be and
where we are and what we see for the
future and all of that in the context of
this amazing company so thank you again
for being here yav tell me a little bit
about yourself as a human you know how
you know how do you think through your
passions the things you care
about yeah so um my actually I started
my career not in computers I actually
I'm a low graduate and I studied
computer as my second degree after I
found out that I don't want to be a
loyer and my journey started with um I
was a graphic designer and then I was U
uh I moved to uh
multimedia um doing a cdrom like
interactive C ROMs which gives away my
age um and then I uh I moved to
Australia for a couple of years I did my
masters in Computing I got connected
back to my uh my childhood passion I
used to um program games as a child at
the age of 13 or something like that uh
so I reconnected to my inner self the
the to the computer geek and from there
everything
started came back to Israel continued to
work in
some Hightech companies in in the
country and uh eventually found the je
frog with uh with two of my co-found
with two co-founders which we used to
run a previous company
together a
consultancy h which we sold to um to the
malam team group uh back in
2005 U and then Jeff fog was created in
2008 so that's in a glimpse my my
journey okay so your starting jrog um
and several months after starting it I
remember 2008 very vividly because I was
well from my end I was in eighth grade
but I remember very very well the stock
market class talking about what's
happening in the world and so I'm very
curious to hear about what it was what
what the first year of jrog was like as
you are unfold as you entering into a
new world of U of of you know from from
Financial perspective but before that
what is the state of software and the
state of of of global digital
Transformations That You observe and
what is sort of the vision that you set
out as the three of you for jrog so
we're jumping a lot ahead um um today
many companies are at uh there are most
of the large companies they already
started the digital transformation uh
moving away to uh to automation like uh
really adopting Automation in the way
they deliver
software um I think and it's it's not a
secret um and this was when jeug was
started it was like the the initial BDS
of this uh of this uh change in the
market where software became so much
engraved in the in the value proposition
of companies like it's um for for many
companies the software they are creating
is really the value of the company
uh sometimes most of the value that that
the company delivers but um even for
companies that which is not the case
software still plays a major part uh I
have some friends that moved Banks
because they didn't like the the the
application of the of the and the user
experience that the bank gave them so
uh again like because software plays
such a major role in our life and it's
no longer surprising to anyone uh the
state of digital transformation is at
its peak currently I think we used to be
in the like early
adopters um and now we're in a phase
where um we're seeing this as as a major
trend for everyone we we with jog we
serve a lot of Enterprises so we have
700 500
7,500 customers around that number many
of them are Enterprises and uh yeah
we're seeing this as it happens we're
seeing huge companies moving to the
cloud adopting um
[Music]
automation all around um so I think
we're at the peak of this uh of this
transformation incredible still a long
way to go for main for the large comp a
lot of legacy to migrate uh but uh it's
undoubtfully happening as we speak do
you envision in 2008 that in the 20 that
you know 2020 and 2024 is going to come
in and you're going to have
7,500 Enterprise clients I mean the I
mean looking at three of you and you
know how you I mean is that is that a is
that what you think is going to
happen no I I don't think
I mean I think anyone that is starting
the startup and I mean you may have a
vision you may H aim to be larger and
you you may want to be the next Google
or Amazon or whatever but I don't think
any entrepreneur can tell you uh from
the kickoff date that this is where
they're going to to read um what what
we've done at Jeff and this is how the
company started so you ask about uh you
asked about
how it all started uh we identifi the
pain okay and this pain got actually
Amplified over the years in different
forms and this pain was around allowing
people to create software that they
trust um initially it was just this
revolution of um creating software from
reusable components mostly open source
obviously and um
and you know when you start to assemble
your software from many many pieces and
you don't have control over these
pieces um it becomes a risk and the
initial risk was just a maybe this open
source software that you're using maybe
it's going to um Get Off the Grid like
vanish from the internet that what this
event specifically was how uh the
trigger for jog
came to me for for for the main product
for the factory um it was a was it a was
it a specific experience or or um or
just a realization that this is a a a
hypothetical problem that could happen
it was a specific incident of a very
popular open source library that was
hosted so this this is precl cloud days
um and it was hosted on a desktop which
went up in Flames at some point
and huge companies couldn't work for for
days trying to uh to scavenge those
those component so
uh that was the that was the like the
the funding incident that uh came to the
realization that you need to provide
trust and I was surprised that uh there
wasn't anything out there that you could
just uh host your um your dependencies
your your open source components
internally and uh and reduce that risk
risk and uh I mean this risk exist in in
other forms today like if you are using
uh open source software today or or just
third party libraries you still run into
a risk with where the quality of the
those libraries can can change over time
um either it can somebody sometimes
people shut down an open source project
sometimes the project gets overtaken
sometimes the developer um kind of gets
uh into a strange Zone like if you know
the faker JS and color J libraries that
where the developer changed the library
to uh to support um I think it was the
the the war in Ukraine H and the
completely Chang the behavior of the
library security issues like
vulnerabilities that people are trying
to inject into your software supply
chain which is the main domain that jeug
operates in today that's making sure
that everything you build is trusted
that you you have full visibility to
every component of your software pretty
much like in in the automotive industry
where you you know how to recall a car
because the a
certain break is was not manufactured in
an ideal way and you know exactly which
cars are driving around and where they
are with this faulty braking system H so
it's the same in software you have many
OEM components that you put into your
software and lots of risk because that
becomes one of the most critical value
for you as a
company H and most of the companies that
are coming for us that they are coming
to to gain this
control the other side of it is that the
world as we know it today is not such a
safe place I mean we experienc it
firstand uh here in Israel unfortunately
but uh in in a global sense there's a
lot of uh EV evil going going around and
people trying to uh to gain benefits
from from software like getting into
your software supply chain and making
like stealing
information extorting companies that
they manage to get into their supply CH
or Wars the products there have been
many incidents over the years uh of
course cryptocurrency Mak makes it a lot
more tangible for people to uh to uh do
this bad stuff and and without getting
caught um so that's that became like a
government level concern today the trust
in software and the risk that software
no it's and I think it's it's quite um
it's quite remarkable how already in
2008 and I'm sure that there were I'm
sure that there were key learnings
throughout that had you understand not
only this specific problem that you face
but then how it actually extrapolates to
every every software in every software
company in the world and every digital
transformation and understanding how
these risks are operating on a global
level and how to generate these tools
that would be that could generalize
across every organization and I think
that's really just you know beyond the
technology and Beyond the idea the
ability to actually execute on a
solution that can service so many
customers and actually do it and I hear
this over and over again about the fact
that you know those that are actually
using the software the solution you know
it's it's just a great great product and
I think that's one of the things that
I've always know looking over the last
few years as I've been inspired by jrog
and and and your work it's it's really
been not just the H the the vision and
the scale but it's been the quality that
you've been H honing in on which leads
me to to looking you as a technology
leader as a CTO how how many um
Engineers or people do you have in the
R&D site of jfrog right now uh we have
around 500
Engineers so that's nearly third of the
company uh
today um obviously we're very engering
oriented so you have um you're yeah
you're you're starting this company um I
assume that very full of people in in
the in the beginning
phases how do you grow to 500 Engineers
how do you maintain a level of quality
how do you see leading this organization
and leading an organization to hundreds
of Engineers while maintaining the
culture maintaining the the quality so
that 15 years later you can actually
execute on thousands of customers yeah
so it's a it's a great question um I
mean
uh and that's something uh um you don't
testify for yourself but that's
something I'm really proud of uh that
sometimes when you interview people or
you meet people they they uh they're
surprised by the age of jeffro like they
the fact that Jeff frog was founded in
2008 uh is a surprise for them because
they think the company is much younger
so um that to maintain the spirit and to
maintain um the The Innovation and the
livelihood of the company and the
culture of course that embodies
everything uh this is something that
eventually it um it comes from the
people that you that you are working
with it comes from the team that you
recruit H and when it comes from the top
it um it kind of trickles down to to
everyone so um it's um it's a challenge
it's uh it gets more challenging uh W
with with size but uh as long as your
leaders uh and the leaders below them
are are the right kind of people
are messaging this culture and behaving
according to this culture then it
actually works this is what I found
out what was the most surprising element
for you in
leading R&D or an R&D organization
whether from a human leadership
perspective or from a technology
leadership perspective a on the on the
on the product side what what really
surprised you in these 15 years that now
looking back you would say to me let's
say as a young entrepreneur now
embarking on my journey that I should
keep in mind in um over the next
decade yeah another very good question
um I think you know when you're creating
a company or you're making a product and
even when releasing a
feature uh that you believe in so what I
found out is that uh it always surprised
me and now less but uh Still Still um
still not trivial even today how easily
customers are with willing to uh replace
something they they have solved by
themselves in in a h way if you solve
their pain if you listen to their pain
and if you come up with the and you get
the feedb from the customers and you you
build something to replace it how easily
they they are adopting this solution
over Homegrown Solutions uh because you
would think there would be some uh job
security and some uh and people would
fall in love with what they built inh
house uh but that's the the like the
rare exception in most cases uh I'm I'm
still a bit surprised by that how fast
customers are willing to adopt something
that solves the the pain they solve
themselves and you have the most
important question um especially for um
from my perspective what has been the
most enjoyable part for you um you're
you know I'm sure it's I only this for
year it's it's crazy roller coaster
obviously everybody says that but uh
what were the highest peaks for you as
an
entrepreneur
um I think two things first is
um it's just uh um getting other
products out there so um we started with
the with the main uh Flagship product
which is still the flagship product
which is artifactory which is our claim
to fame and this is how we
um we got to to a place to a very
central place where we have full control
over everything that goes into a release
and um out as a release in a company and
then when you start adding not
functionalities but building a full
platform and adding other
products um it was a very educating
process first I mean we were for warned
by uh years about how difficult it's
going to be and uh um and they were
right and uh uh it was a a really tough
uh process to to get out there with a
platform rather than a single product
we're still learning by the way but this
was like a a huge achievement coming
with a lot of uh of uh scratches and uh
sculls um the other thing relates to the
first thing I spoke about it's seeing
customers uh see seeing a pain being
solved seeing customers adopting what
you're
creating uh I think that there there's
such a huge Joy there that uh and I
think this is what keeps me
thinking uh it's like somebody that you
know like a chef in in a in a restaurant
that uh enjoys seeing other people uh um
enjoying their dishes so so I think it's
the same way in software and it's not
just myself it's the it's the whole team
of course thatth when you create
something that customers adopt There Is
No Greater Joy than that it's like the
biggest satisfaction that you can get as
a as a software entrepreneur or or
just the softw
guy I love it y have thank you so much
for for your time for the inspiration I
know how busy you are and I really
appreciate it we'll let you get back to
Leading um and such an incredible group
and organization thank you besides the
20 minutes for as a now as a as a
technologist and engineer as an
entrepreneur myself thank you for being
a sort of a spotlight um on my journey
um to you and to your co-founders so
thank you for that H this is why I
started this show so I get to actually
ask the questions that I care about um
with the companies and entrepreneurs
that I'm inspired by so thank you very
very much and uh best of luck with
continuing to with the next few thousand
clients you too M it was my pleasure
thanks for having me
here